we've got an interesting voicemail today
the phone number to call is two one nine
to david p this voicemail has what i
guess is now the requisite podcast
playing in the background pause to the
show to call in remember you can just
hit pause and then call me and then
resume but in any case you'll hear my
voice in the background let's take a
listen to this voicemail hey david i was
just wondering what are your thoughts on
if president Trump was to lose the
election and he doesn't want to leave
office what we do listen don't worry
about that okay there's a couple
different things there number one don't
put the cart before the horse let's
defeat Trump first before we worry about
whether he'll leave office that's the
most important thing because if we focus
too much on what will happen if Trump
refuses to leave office Trump might get
himself reelected and we don't want that
that's number one so just go vote number
two if Donald Trump loses in November on
January twenty first twenty twenty one
he will no longer be the President of
the United States he just will not be
the president okay that's the way that
it is written in the law and I am not
particularly worried about Donald Trump
successfully not turning over power to
Joe Biden if he loses in November I do
believe Trump will claim that it was
rigged I do believe that it is likely
that many trumpets could be moved to get
on the streets possibly with guns if
Donald Trump convinces them that it was
rigged and that really Donald Trump won
I I believe all of that that could well
happen but Trump will leave because he
will not be the president anymore
on January 21st now I know that there
are some hypotheses floating around
here's what Trump could do to prevent
this from going to Joe Biden in January
if indeed he were to lose most of those
scenarios actually lead to the Speaker
of the House becoming president it's
important to understand it doesn't mean
there is not some hypothetical scenario
that you could dream up if some way
Trump could remain in the White House
I don't worry about voting right now
okay that's the important thing we've
got three and a half months until
November let's win first
then we'll have two more two and a half
more months to make sure Donald Trump
vacates the White House and we'll deal
with that after November third if that
comes up let's just leave it there we've
got a great bonus show for you today we
are going to talk about the US budget
deficit where are the deficit hawks
they're very very quiet as the US budget
deficit has hit another all-time high
Disney World is also offering masks free
relaxation zones I will discuss how much
would I have to be paid to go to Disney
World right now not how much would I pay
would I go with it how much would I have
to be paid to go and we are also going
to talk about China announcing some
sanctions against Marco Rubio and Ted
Cruz two Republican senators retaliatory
sanctions against them all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
don't miss it become a member at join
pakman.com